another month of summer another batch of
free games for Xbox Live Gold members if
you're one of them and want to know what
you can play in August I've got you
covered and don't forget to hit that
subscribe button to be the first to know
about the games with gold lineup every
month
first up slime rancher is leaving early
access for a full debut on Xbox one you
can probably guess exactly what this
game is just based on the title but
here's the elevator pitch rancher
beatrix LeBeau explores an open-world to
collect and raise a bunch of little
slimes using her handy vacuum backpack
aka backpack slime rancher will be
available all month long also coming to
Xbox one is trials fusion this is the
fifth game in the trial series but the
first one with a futuristic setting it
also adds quadbikes and freestyle stunts
and includes a handy track editor where
you can make your own ridiculous stunt
courses eight player multiplayer ain't
too bad either trials fusion will be
available from August 16th through
September 15th on the 360 side you'll be
able to get your hands on the original
Bayonetta 1 of platinum games first
titles it's a stylish action brawler
with plenty of bullets at your disposal
and bad angels to take down if you
haven't experienced which time yet now's
your chance it'll be available from
August 1st through the 15th and finally
360 gamers can also try out Red Faction
Armageddon the sequel to Red Faction
gorillas still has plenty of cave walls
and buildings to tear down but you can
also rebuild structures using the Nano
forge Armageddon will be available from
August 16th through the 31st and
remember that both this and Bayonetta
can also be played on Xbox one
thanks to backwards compatibility and
those are your free games with gold for
August 2017 you can always check out
gameplay clips and reviews for these
titles over at GameSpot and if you want
to keep up with all of our top stories
you can grab the official game spot now
app on iOS and Android
[Music]
you